ladies and gentlemen please welcome Tom
Cruise
you
when the great director Billy Wilder was
asked what makes a movie unforgettable
his answer was simple a little bit of
magic we're all here tonight or sitting
at home watching because something came
off a movie screen a little bit of magic
touched our lives and you always
remember where you were the theater the
popcorn the people you were with what
had happened it's 1968 my family was
living in Ottawa Canada
the movie was Stanley Kubrick's 2001 a
Space Odyssey I couldn't stop thinking
about it what is life what is space what
is existence I was six years old
and I knew right then and there I wanted
to be an astronaut my family traveled a
lot the white-hot trail of Jaws I was a
Louisville Kentucky senior year New
Jersey Apocalypse Now Valley Forge
Pennsylvania Raging Bull I knew I wanted
to be an actor and good times in four
times movies were my lifesaver in the
last September came an event that would
change us actor friends said to me what
are we doing what are we doing is it
important is it even it important what I
do and what have a night like tonight
should we celebrate the joy and magic
the movies bring well dare I say it more
than ever
a small scene a gesture even a glance
between characters can cross lines break
through barriers melt prejudice just
plain make us laugh brings us all
together a little bit of magic that's
just me tonight we are going to listen
to you
documentary filmmaker Errol Morris Criss
crossed America asking moviegoers and
culture makers a question what a movies
mean to you and you answered so let's
expand this beautiful stage and every
one of your homes and maybe even some of
you will answer this question as you
stand on this stage tonight what a
movies mean to you
so pull up a sofa it's just us talking
it's Oscar